nowadays were pretty tough on people who
have a certain kind of faith people who
are afraid of getting close people who
needs to sit alone for quite a long time
every day people who don't always find
it easy to say what's on their minds
people who need their space we say these
old people have got a failed intimacy
and that's not a good thing to have it
can get you in trouble but criticizing
the fear of intimacy doesn't seem right
or very productive at all we'd be far
better off with a different approach for
a start if someone is scared of
something it's never a great idea just
to say they're silly and there's nothing
to be worried about it's a lot more
effective say we're a bit scared too and
that is actually normal to worry then
it's as good I did try to understand the
fear where has it come from there's
almost always a history to someone who
is afraid of intimacy the history were
getting close to other people got them
hurt so that closeness has become a
problem we should also take on board
just how much of life is about not being
intimate
Murli age we're taught we need to be
strong independent and brave we need to
hide our oceans not say how we're
feeling bottle up what's going on inside
it is no wonder we sometimes find it
hard to change gear and become masters
at the art of intimacy it's not
surprising if we do get a bit stuck and
not quite know what to do with requests
to say exactly how we feel we've been
out in the world too long
we're battle-hardened and just not used
to it we might need a little time so
let's go easy on those with a fear of
intimacy they're not bad people they
just find a difficult thing tricky and
we should be on hand to help them with
gentleness and understanding
you